will be a new world champion this
weekend whose name is not Magnus Carlson
this match has been won for the history
books as we've seen both Jan napomnishi
and dingly ren battle their way to a tie
score after game 13 ended in a tightly
held draw we have a handshake the game
is in the books that means we still have
a tight match that means it's Winner
Takes all when the players return to the
board this weekend with the chaos we've
seen in this match it's possible that
Ding or NEPA will go for the decisive
result in game 14. if drawn will go to
tie breaks this match has been a roller
coaster both Ding and nepo have traded
blunders brilliant moves and wins a far
cry from the drawfield matches of
previous World Championships we've seen
some thrilling chess
with Carlson's abdication of the throne
who will lift up the crown will it be
ding or nepo and that's why